Hey guys, Matt here with Science or Fiction.
Is there a speed that would harm humans?
There are a bunch of human speed records that
are going to be broken in the coming decades
as we develop the technology to travel thousands
of miles in minutes by land, send commercial
flights into low-earth orbit, and attempt
to get humans to Mars.
So with all of these possibilities on the
horizon, a question you might be asking yourself
is “How fast is too fast?”
Well, first of all, wherever you are, no matter
what you are doing, you are traveling nearly
67,000 mph around the sun.
It just doesn’t feel that way because the
Earth, and therefore humans, have been traveling
at that constant rate for, well, you know,
kind of a while.
We can actually survive any speed, as long
as it remains constant.
It’s when acceleration enters the equation
that things can get pretty tricky.
In fact, if you accelerate at a high enough
rate, you will pass out and very possibly
die.
This is because of what happens to the human
body when it experiences g-force, or the unit
of measure for acceleration.
It’s based on Earth’s gravitational pull.
One “G” is the force applied to an object
by gravity while on the Earth’s surface.
It’s also the force that determines how
much we weigh.
So, simply put, if a human experiences three
Gs, they experience a force on their bodies
that is three times their weight.
We can experience the G force in different
ways.
If we accelerate horizontally like in a car
or train, we can experience g-force either
front-to-back or side-to-side.
We can actually withstand quite a bit of g-force
when it’s hitting us horizontally.
It’s when things go vertical, which mostly
happens only on airplanes, roller coasters,
or during space launches, that things get
much more dangerous much more quickly.
Vertical g-force can be experienced negatively
(foot to head) or positively (head to foot).
Both can be experienced in an airplane or
rocket, and both can pose serious threats
to our health because of what happens to all
the liquid in our bodies under these circumstances.
With a high level of negative Gs, blood can
end up collecting in our heads.
Sometimes a “red out” will occur, with
the lower eyelids swelling up so much that
they cover the pupils.
If enough blood pools in the head, which can
happen around 2 or 3 negative Gs, a person
will lose consciousness.
Yikes.
And other scary stuff happens when force is
applied from head-to-foot and blood starts
to pool in the lowest parts of our bodies.
At 1 G, or normal conditions, our bodies require
22 millimeters of mercury blood pressure to
pump blood from the heart to the brain.
That requirement doubles at 2 G, triples at
3 G, and so on.
There’s a certain point at which our bodies
can no longer muster the energy needed to
pump the blood, which happens around 4 or
5 Gs.
Blood ends up pooling in the feet, and the
rest of the body receives such a lack of oxygen
that a person first loses vision due to a
lack of blood flow to the eyes and then consciousness
altogether when the brain loses enough of
its blood flow.
This phenomenon is known as G-LOC, or G-induced
loss of consciousness.
Both head-to-foot and foot-to-head vertical
g-forces can eventually lead to death if they
last long enough.
So, given that humankind is on the precipice
of breaking many speed records, and given
that many of the airplanes and spacecrafts
that will be involved could one day fly your
average Joe across the country at record speeds,
how can we make sure that we, you know, don’t
die?
Pilots do a number of things to train for
serious g-s.
The better shape they are in, the more able
they are to control their body’s blood flow
with their muscles.
Leg and abdominal muscles must be particularly
strong so that when pilots tense these muscles,
they can keep the blood from draining to their
legs while experiencing positive g-force.
Well, it’s sort of unrealistic to expect
everyone to have abs of steel, so other solutions
might be needed if we are to expect average
people to eventually accelerate at rates currently
only safe for fighter pilots.
One solution could anti-g suits, which pilots
have been using since World War II.
They utilize air bladders to keep the blood
in our bodies where it should be.
Fortunately, we haven’t quite reached the
point where people like you or me (unless
there are a lot of fighter pilots watching
this episode, then I take that back) are going
to be accelerating at deathly rates.
There is still time for us to figure out how
to manage all that.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future check out THE AGE OF AEROSPACE.COM
Did you know we learned a lot about how g-force
affects the body from one guy shooting himself
down a track in a rocket sled?
It’s true, check it out here.
Before you do that, make sure to subscribe
and be sure to keep coming back to Seeker
for more videos.